> THIS MORNING, WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT TWO TIMES MASTERS
CHAMON BUBBA WATSON IS LEAVING
THE PGA TOUR FOR THE
CONTROVERSIAL SAUDI-BACKED LIV
GOLF SERIES.
HE IS THE LATEST TO JOIN THE
BREAKAWAY LEAGUE.
AND FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO TEE OFF WITH TWO OTHER
FORMER PGA GOLFERS WHO ALSO
JOINED THIS LIV LEAGUE.
TRUMP HAS BEEN CRITICIZED BY
FAMILIES AND SURVIVORS OF
THE 9/11 TERRORIST ATTACK FOR
HOSTING THE TOURNAMENT AND FOR
WORKING WITH THE MAN THAT U.S.
INTELLIGENCE SAYS IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE DEATH OF JOURNALIST
JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
IN AN INTERVIEW, TRUMP CLAIMS
THE CONTROVERSY AROUND KHA
KHASHOGGI'S KILLING HAS, QUOTE,
TOTALLY DIED DOWN.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS IS CNN
CONTRIBUTOR BOB COSTAS.
THIS IS, BOB THIS IS ALL
HAPPENING -- IT IS HAPPENING SO
CLOSE TO THE WORLD TRADE CENTER.
IT IS HAPPENING IN THE SHADOW OF
IT.
>> SOME 700 PLUS OF THE VICTIMS
ON 9/11, 21 YEARS AGO, WERE FROM
NEW JERSEY, SOME OF THEM FROM
THE BEDMINSTER AREA.
THE 9/11 FAMILIES ARE VERY HURT
ABOUT THIS, VERY UPSET, AND
THERE WILL BE PROTESTS OUTSIDE
THE GROUNDS, BUT IF WE LEARNED
ANYTHING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP,
WHICH IT SHOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN
VERY LONG TO LEARN, IS THAT HE
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT ANY
PRINCIPLE, INCLUDING AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY OR ANY PERSON, HE
CARES ABOUT NOTHING OTHER THAN
HIS OWN PERCEIVED
SELF-INTERESTS.
AND THEN THERE IS THE ASPECT OF
GRIEVANCE AND REVENGE.
HE WAS UPSET BECAUSE THE PGA
PULLED OUT FOLLOWING JANUARY 6th
THE LAST YEAR, FOLLOWING THOSE
EVENTS, THEY PULLED THE PGA
TOURNAMENT FROM THE BEDMINSTER
COURSE.
SO THIS IS AN ELEMENT OF
GRIEVANCE ON HIS PART BECAUSE AS
WE ALL KNOW, HE IS, AFTER ALL,
THE MOST PERSECUTED MAN IN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND HE'S
QUALIFIED TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
HE'S A SCHOLAR OF HISTORY.
>> HE -- DONALD TRUMP SAYING
THAT JAMAL KHASHOGGI ISSUE HAS
TOTALLY DIED DOWN AS A
JUSTIFICATION, THAT'S A
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN EVEN THE
GOLFERS WHO ARE TRYING TO
JUSTIFY IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL, WHAT CAN YOU POSSIBLY
SAY?
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
BELIEVE WHAT THEY WANT TO
BELIEVE WILL ACCEPT THAT.
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THIS REALITY
WILL NOT.
>> BECAUSE THE GOLFERS, I MEAN,
THEIR LINE IS THEY SAY GOLF IS A
FORCE FOR GOOD.
>> YEAH.
>> IT IS THE WAY THEY TRY TO
TWIST IT AND SAY, IT IS NOT
SPORTS WASHING, THIS IS ACTUALLY
US USING GOLF FOR GOOD.
THAT'S NOT WHERE DONALD TRUMP IS
COMING FROM HERE.
>> NO.
IT IS NOT.
AS WE DISCUSSED BEFORE ON THIS
PROGRAM, IF THE LIV GOLF TOUR
WAS BACKED BY ANYTHING OTHER
THAN THIS SORT OF ASSOCIATION,
WITH THE SAUDIS, AND WE MENSED
JAMAL KHASHOGGI, BUT THERE IS A
WHOLE LIST OF OTHER HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AND THE CONNECTION
TO 9/11 ITSELF, BACKED BY ANY
OTHER ENTITY, IT WOULD JUST BE A
RIVAL TOUR.
AND AS WE NOTED BEFORE, GREG
NORMAN AND MANY OF THE PLAYERS
ON THE TOUR HAVE ISSUES WITH THE
PGA.
AND THOSE ISSUES COULD BE
ADDRESSED IF THERE WERE AN
ALTERNATIVE.
AS LONG AS THAT ALTERNATIVE WAS
NOT BACKED BY AN OBJECTIONABLE
REGIME.
THAT'S THE ENTIRE CRUX OF THE
ISSUE.
>> AND, AGAIN, WE TALKED ABOUT
IT HERE BEFORE, BOB, BUT I WANT
YOU TO MAKE THE DISTINCTION, YOU
SEE THIS AS DIFFERENT THAN
PRESIDENT BIDEN GOING TO SAUDI
ARABIA AND MEETING WITH THE
SAUDI CROWN PRINCE.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW I'M
QUALIFIED TO TALK ABOUT THAT,
BUT OVER THE COURSE OF HISTORY
LEADERS OF ADVERSARIAL NATIONS
HAVE HAD TO MEET FOR REASONS OF
REAL POLITICS.
I'LL SAY THIS, JUST A PERSONAL
THING, A FIST BUMP IS USUALLY AN
AFFIRMATION, YOU SHAKE HANDS
WITH OPPONENTS.
THE HANDSHAKE COMES FROM, YOU
KNOW, WAR, LONG AGO, I'M PUTTING
OUT MY HAND TO INDICATE I'M NOT
HOLDING A WEAPON.
YOU FIST BUMP SOMEONE WHEN IT IS
AN AFFIRMATION, GOOD JOB, GOOD
TO SEE YOU, YOU'RE MY PAL.
I THOUGHT THE FIST BUMP WAS
WORSE THAN A HANDSHAKE, BUT
THAT'S PROBABLY A TRIVIAL
MATTER.
>> WHY DO YOU SEE THIS DIFFERENT
THEN?
SOME PEOPLE WHO DEFENDED THE LIV
TOUR SAID, WELL, WHAT ABOUT
SPONSORS OF THE PGA WHO DO
BUSINESS IN SAUDI ARABIA, YOU
KNOW, WHY AREN'T YOU ALL OVER
THAT, WHY ISN'T THAT SO BAD?
OR ATHLETES WHO GO TO COUNTRIES
WITH QUESTIONABLE HUMAN RIGHTS
RECORDS, WHY ISN'T THAT THE SAME
THING?
>> WELL, THERE IS A BIT OF WHAT
ABOUTISM BECAUSE WHO SAYS THAT
ANY OF US NECESSARILY APPROVE OF
THOSE BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE HERE IS WE
DON'T KNOW WHO ANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE ARE.
THE SAUDIS ARE INTERESTED IN
HAVING PHIL MICKELSON AND DUSTIN
JOHNSON AND WHOM EVER ELSE AND
NOW BUBBA WATSON BECAUSE THAT
PUTS A CERTAIN HAPPY FACE TO
SOME IN THE AUDIENCE, ON THIS
ENTIRE ENDEAVOR BECAUSE PEOPLE
FEEL WARM FEELINGS, THEY'RE
ENTERTAINED BY SPORTS.
THAT'S DIFFERENT.
ALSO, IF YOU GO TO CHINA BECAUSE
THE OLYMPICS ARE THERE, YOU AS
AN OLYMPIAN ARE NOT IN BUSINESS
WITH THE CHINESE.
YOU MAY EVEN SAY I WISH THE
OLYMPICS WEREN'T HERE, BUT
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE BEING HELD.
IN THIS CASE, THERE IS A DIRECT
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
EACH OF THESE GOLFERS AND THE
SAUDI REGIME.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS A BIT OF A
HISTORY TRYING TO GET INTO PRO
SPORTS IN A MAJOR WAY.
>> YEAH, HE WANTED TO BUY THE
BUFFALO BILLS AT ONE TIME,
WANTED TO GET INTO THE NFL,
OWNED THE JERSEY GENERALS OF THE
USFL, DOUG FLUTIE ON THE ONE
HAND, HERSCHEL WALKER ON THE
OTHER, ANOTHER BRIGHT SHINING
POLITICAL LIGHT, SO, YEAH, HE
HAS THAT HISTORY AND WE KNOW
THAT HE WILL NURSE A GRIEVANCE
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
>> DO YOU SEE THIS TEMPLATE
PLAYING OUT WITH OTHER LEAGUES,
BASEBALL, ET CETERA, BASKETBALL?
>> YOU KNOW, MARK CUBAN WHO OWNS
THE DALLAS MAVERICKS EXPRESSED
SOME CONCERN ABOUT THAT.
BUT I SEE IT MAYBE, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE IN TENNIS, YOU COULD DO
IT.
BUT TEAM SPORTS ARE DEPENDENT
UPON A CERTAIN KIND OF HISTORY.
YOU CAN'T JUST PUT ON AN
EXHIBITION IN WHICH AARON JUDGE
MIGHT HIT 62 HOME RUNS OR SHOWY
OHTANI MIGHT DO WHAT HE DOES,
OUTSIDE OF THE CONTEXT OF THE
COMPETITION, TEAM SPORTS ARE
DIFFERENT.
>> ALSO, THERE IS SOMETHING
ABOUT A GOLFER AND TENNIS PLAYER
IN A WAY ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S WHERE I'M AT.
>> THE TEAMS ARE BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZATIONS IN AND OF
THEMSELVES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO IT.
>> THE APPARATUS IS SO MUCH
LARGER THAN JUST SAYING, OKAY,
WE'RE HAVING A GOLF TOURNAMENT,
YOU SHOW UP HERE, YOU TEE OFF,
THE APPARATUS OF A LEAGUE, THE
SCHEDULING, AND EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT GOES INTO IT.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN RIVAL
LEAGUES THROUGH THE YEARS, BUT
ALL THOSE RIVAL LEAGUES TO THE
EXTENT IN WHICH THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL, THEY WERE ABSORBED.
THE AFL WAS ABSORBED BY THE NFL.
PART OF THE ABA ABSORBED BY THE
NBA.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
SPORT LIKE GOLF, IT MEANS IT IS
YOUR DECISION.
YOU CAN'T HANG IT ON A LEAGUE OR
ON A TEAM.
SO IT IS YOUR DECISION TO GO.
SO, LIKE, A BUBBA WATSON, THIS
IS -- WHAT DOES THIS DO TO A
LEGACY FOR BUBBA WATSON?
HE WAS ONCE NUMBER TWO IN THE
WORLD.
>> AND WON THE MASTERS TWICE.
>> TWICE.
NOW WHAT?
>> SUPPOSEDLY THE FOUR MAJORS,
THE BRITISH OPEN, THE U.S. OPEN,
THE PGA AND THE MASTERS, ARE NOT
AFFECTED BY THE SUSPENSIONS
WHICH THE PGA TOUR HAS HANDED
OUT TO THESE PLAYERS.
SO THEY CAN STILL PLAY IN THE
MAJORS AND YOUR LEGACY IS
LARGELY DETERMINED BY WHAT YOU
DO IN THE MAJORS.
NOBODY IS SAYING THAT THESE
PLAYERS DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO IT.
THE QUESTION IS IT THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
AND ALSO WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
GOLF GRIEVANCES, WE MENSE MENTI
THE MAJORS, THE BRITISH OPEN IS
OFTEN CONTESTED AT TURNBERRY,
BUT THE RIOYAL AND ANCIENT CLUB
HAS NOT EXTENDED ANY OLIVE
BRANCH TO DONALD TRUMP, WHICH IS
PROBABLY ALSO STICKING IN HIS
CRAW.
>> AS A JUNIOR GOLFER WHO WENT
TO WATCH GREG NORMAN HIT SAND
SHOTS AND HE WAS AMAZING, IT IS
DISAPPOINTING TO WATCH.
I HAD NO IDEA SO MANY YEARS
LATER I WOULD BE DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
BOB, LOVELY TO HAVE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING.
>> IT WAS LOVELY.
THANK YOU.